I was born in Hamilton, Ontario, Canada.
But I grew up mostly in Long Island, New York.
My ancestral homeland is in Jaipur, Rajasthan,
India.
There are a lot of academics in my family.
My mother is a mathematician, and my grandfather
was a professor of Sanskrit and ancient Indian
history.
A lot of mathematics I learned as a child
was through what he taught me about the rhythms
of Sanskrit poetry.
I think mathematicians do mathematics for
reasons that are very similar to those of
musicians playing music, or any artist doing
their art.
It's all about trying to contribute to a certain
understanding of ourselves and the world around us.
One key to solving hard mathematical problems
that people have been thinking about for many
years, is to think about them in a totally
different way.
One of the most exciting moments of discovery
for me occurred when I was a graduate student
at Princeton.
Those days I had been thinking about Gauss
composition.
So Gauss composition is a method by which
one can take two quadratic expressions and
two variables and combine them to produce
a third such quadratic expression.
At one moment it just clicked — it was around
midnight, when I usually go to sleep — that
if I take a Rubik's cube and I cut off the
top layer and then I put numbers in the remaining
little cubes, that that would lead to a cubic
analogue of Gauss composition.
I went on to discover 12 more analogues of
Gauss composition over the next couple years,
but that first one suddenly opened this door.
And that door was opened in part because I
was playing with toys.
A lot of the work I've done over the past
several years has involved developing techniques
in the geometry of numbers in order to solve
problems about the number of number fields
having bounded discriminate or the number
of rational points on random elliptic curves
or higher genius curves.
These proofs about the existence or non-existence
of rational solutions to elliptic curve equations
have in particular now led to a proof, which
is joint work with Chris Skinner and Wei Zhang,
that most elliptic curves satisfy the Birch
and Swinnerton-Dyer conjecture.
Some of the most applicable mathematics that's
occurred in history has been discovered not
for the purpose of the application but because
one was just searching for the most beautiful
mathematics out there.